on this historic day
um okay
um
so wanted to
first start by outlining uh our security
assistance to ukraine and there's been a
lot of good questions about this and we
thought this would be a helpful rundown
for all of you it's the department of
defense also put out a fact sheet that
has this detailed as well uh the
security assistance the biden
administration is providing to ukraine
is enabling critical success on the
battlefield against the russian invading
force the number one reason that they're
able to fight back is their bravery and
courage the number two reason is the
security assistance uh that we are
providing and we are providing in
coordination with our allies and
partners we are working around the clock
to fulfill ukraine's priority security
assistance requests delivering weapons
from u.s stocks when they are available
and facilitating the delivery of weapons
by allies and partners when their
systems better suit ukraine's needs all
of the anti-armor and anti-air systems
from the two packages of security
assistance the president approved in
march have been delivered uh we are
continuing work with allies and partners
to identify additional weapons systems
to help the ukrainian military defend
its country obviously there was the
announcement about the s 300s earlier
today
and our efforts to work
to backfill that
at president zielenski's request this
includes helping ukraine acquire
long-range anti-aircraft systems and
munitions that they are trained to use
more than 30 nations have sent ukraine's
security assistance thanks in part to
the leadership of president biden and
diplomacy that he has been implementing
for months now on april 5th we announced
an additional 100 million dollars in
security assistance to ukraine through
presidential drawdown authority we also
announced 300 million dollars in
security assistance on april 1st under
authorities provided by the ukraine
security assistance initiative these
announcements bring the u.s commitment
to more than 1.7 billion dollars in
security assistance since russia's
february 24th invasion and 2.4 billion
dollars since the beginning of the
administration i will not read through
all of this for you you can all of
course read it yourself and we will
provide
all of the lists to all of you should if
you did not receive the department of
defense fact sheet also wanted to note
that today according to a new
independent study the biden
administration's historic vaccination
program saved 2.3 million lives in the
united states prevented 17 million
hospitalizations in 66 million cases and
avoided 900 billion dollars in health
care costs over the past 15 months the
president has mounted a successful
nationwide vaccination effort while
executing a comprehensive strategy on
treatments testing and more as a result
schools are open our economy is booming
and importantly today's report shows
we've spared millions of families the
immeasurable loss that too many others
have suffered and because of the
president's comprehensive response we've
entered a new moment in our fight
against the virus while covet isn't over
americans now have more tools than ever
before to protect themselves and this
country is moving forward safely back to
many of our more normal routines
unfortunately republicans in congress
are holding up critical funding we need
to make even more progress to save even
more lives and to stay prepared against
any potential surges or variance in
action will leave our nation less
prepared for future surges and variants
it will mean fewer vaccines treatments
and tests for the american people this
is deeply disappointing and it should be
unacceptable to every american i also
wanted to give you a sense of the week
ahead just one trip uh next week that we
announced earlier today at this point
there could be more on thursday the
president will travel to greensboro
north carolina to discuss
his administration's efforts to make
more in america rebuild our supply
chains here at home and bring down costs
for the american people as part of
building a better america following that
trip he will travel to camp david where
he will remain over the easter weekend
and then finally as i've been doing a
little bit this week i just want to
shout out some amazing colleagues i have
lewis who we have stolen from fema not
really stolen he's a detailer well he's
a fellow actually um we've had him since
november soon they will steal him back
um and lewis has been
remarkable lewis uh has been reading
russian media which comes in use in
great use
he has been tracking down a range of
coverage about the war in ukraine he has
been
under relentless uh in in giving us
updates and providing this information
and we're incredibly grateful to lewis
and we'll be sad to see you go back to
fema to do very important work uh many
of you know amanda finney i call her the
mayor because she knows every person
seemingly who works in the building on
the complex which is about 2 000 people
i would not survive this job without
amanda finney you probably would all not
have received all the help you have
received about a range of things without
amanda finney she is smart sassy
level-headed stable
she's remarkable and uh we may all work
for her one day in some capacity i
certainly may
but i am very grateful to her so just
wanted to shout that out and her yellow
suit is very joyful for a joyful day
okay with that it's a friday
thanks so much i've got a couple things
sure um first on this uh the missile
attack at this train station does the
administration think that russia might
have intentionally targeted the
transition knowing that there would be a
lot of civilians there
well what we've seen over the course of
the last
six weeks or
more than that um has been um what the
president himself is characterized as uh
war crimes which is the intentional
targeting
of civilians this is yet another
horrific atrocity committed by russia
striking civilians who are trying to
evacuate and reach safety where we are
now is we're going to support efforts to
investigate this attack as we document
russia's actions hold them accountable
we will continue to surge of security
assistance and weapons deliveries to
help ukraine defend their country
obviously the targeting of civilians
would certainly be a war crime and we've
already called a range of the actions
we've seen to date a war crime but we're
going to be supporting efforts to
investigate exactly what happened here
okay uh changing topics uh senior
administration officials have
said publicly gone on tv uh suggesting
it's possible the president could get
um i'm wondering is the administration
attempting to prepare the public for the
possibilities of the president getting
the dressing positive well what we're
trying to do is be as transparent and
direct with the american people
as possible about the fact that
while the president
is
takes a range of protocols we have a
range of protocols in place here that
are aligned and even beyond
the cdc requirements um those include as
we've outlined here
many times in the past
testing before you see the president
testing before you travel with him
social distancing when possible
we believe we have the tools and
protocol
to
to address uh this point we are in in
the virus but like anyone else uh the
president may at some point uh test
positive for covid and while we have
seen uh an increase uh in recent i would
just note while we have seen an increase
in cases around people i should just say
that some of us may know
i would also note that cases remain down
95 since the height of omicron that is
fact that is data even as we've seen
cases of people we know but what is
important for the american people to
know is that he has taken a range of
precautions as we all have but he's also
taken steps like getting the second
booster as he did last week in public
and his doctors
are comfortable uh that he could
continue to carry out his duties uh
because of all these steps and
precautions and protections he's taken
uh and and we certainly that's one of
the reasons we encourage the rest of the
american public to do the same go ahead
do you yeah this is the first time that
we've heard uh white house officials
sort of describe it as a certain
possibility that the president could get
cobit are you saying that you think it's
more possible now given sort of the
little outbreak that we're seeing in dc
right now
no we're just saying that it is a
possibility again we are cases are down
95 percent across the country since the
height of omicron uh while cases are up
in washington dc they're also far below
the height of the cases and where they
were in omicron but it is also the case
that despite all the precautions we take
and even with the president being double
boosted he could still test positive for
kovid just as people know many people in
the white house have many people in the
press corps have that is a possibility
and we want to be transparent with the
american public about that
by our rough count here you have at
least 18 politicians and people close to
the president who's now tested positive
this week though you've reiterated all
the extra precautions that you are
taking to try and keep him safe from the
extra masking and testing protocol but
just to be safe if you considered maybe
cutting down some of the big indoor
events or scaling back any changing sort
of your tactic with some of these events
well clearly we did the event uh the
historic event today outside that was in
part to ensure that we could have a huge
number of people on the south lawn
celebrating
the confirmation of justice kentucky
brown jackson but also we know that
having events outside is
better for safety protocols there's no
question about that but what's important
for the american people to know and
understand is that because of all the
steps we've taken because the president
is double boosted uh because uh you know
obviously he has access to the best
healthcare in the world but his doctors
have assessed that these are risks that
can be taken we risk assessed just like
everybody out in the country and it's
important for him to be able to continue
his presidential duties now and even if
he tests positive in the future just
like americans out there in the country
are taking their kids to school they go
to the grocery store uh maybe they're
making a decision to go to dinner uh
this is a time where we are certainly
living with the virus but we have a
range of tools at our disposal to do
that
go ahead um thanks jim a couple of quick
questions on oil and then one on the
french election um we have some
reporting showing that the
administration is considering uh easing
sanctions to allow some oil imports from
venezuela as a
way to replace uh banned energy
shipments from russia can you talk a
little bit about any such considerations
i'm not aware of that being under
consideration okay uh okay at the moment
is it is it going to perhaps be
considered for
it has not been uh so i'm not aware of
being in the construction okay and and
one other one on when uh dulip was in
india
uh he delivered this uh warning to india
to not raise uh purchases of russian oil
and we were wondering if uh perhaps
sanctions along similar lines are being
considered for other nations asking them
to keep purchases of russian oil only
limited to previous levels and perhaps
not first i wouldn't characterize it as
a warning nor did we at the time he went
and had a constructive conversation and
made clear that while it's the decision
of each individual country including
india to determine whether they're going
to import russian oil it is only one to
two percent of their imports about 10
percent of their imparts is from the
united states and so he conveyed of
course they should abide by sanctions uh
which are not related to that decision
but also we would be here to help them
diversify uh and move towards even
reducing further beyond the one to two
percent is that decision perhaps being
relayed also to other countries asking
them to perhaps follow the same
guidelines
well we conveyed every country to abide
by sanctions and we've conveyed to a
range of european countries as you know
and as we've talked about that as they
work to diversify their energy sources
uh that we are here to assist in those
efforts and there are a range of steps
we've taken including uh efforts on lng
i mean that's natural gas of course but
efforts on lng and moving some resources
from asia and other places and ensuring
that there are options to uh for any
country that wants to to diversify their
energy sources
in one of the french elections
are you watching the french elections uh
coming up this sunday perhaps with any
concerns especially with the rise of uh
le pen who is a far right candidate
running against macron
uh we are certainly watching the
elections uh but i don't have any
prediction of what the outcome will be
and once there is an outcome i'm sure we
will speak to it right understanding
it's a fluid situation but the
atrocities in puja uh serve as an
accelerant towards the the latest
sanctions package um the coordination
between that we announced it two days
ago yes um is there any sense that the
strike that we saw this morning will
also accelerate talks on additional
sanctions between the coordinated palace
well i would say just go to go back to a
couple of days ago that obviously the
sanctions package we announced on
wednesdays uh with some the biggest bank
in russia at spare bank uh certainly
that was augmented uh as a result of uh
the atrocities that we were seeing in
bucha and what we have done to date and
we will continue to do is look at
unfortunately the continued atrocities
that we're seeing in the country and
assess how that's going to impact
sanctions consequences and obviously
additional security assistance so that's
how we've been evaluating and working
with our allies to date and i'm certain
uh given uh the the video footage we've
seen on airwaves across the world and
photos that this will be a part of the
discussion that our national security
officials are having with their
counterparts moving forward okay um on
the s300
it's been
fairly apparent for the last several
weeks that that was a process that you
guys were engaged in yeah um i know you
are deliberately ambiguous as to some of
the other processes that may be taking
place but is it fair to say that there
are multiple other tracks
that are similarly far down the line for
other weapon systems or how can you
characterize how far along you are
uh compared to where you are now
on other systems so well one i mean part
of our objective here and the s 300s are
an example of that is to see that we can
get defensive equipment that ukrainians
are trained on and that we know uh it
can be effective move to ukraine so we
are of course grateful to slovakia and
we work closely with slovakia to also
meet their defense needs and part of our
considerations here as we're looking at
the list of requests that the ukrainians
have is what do we have access to here
in the united states what military
equipment do we have access to there are
systems we may not have access access to
or may we may not even have those
systems so how can we work with
countries around the world like slovakia
to meet those needs so there are a range
of those conversations happening with
our partners and allies at the same time
i i will tell you that often it is the
preference of these partners and allies
not to be public about these
conversations and at times it is the
preference of the ukrainians and we
certainly respect that
one final one um it's been a pretty
historic 24 hours
for the history of the supreme court for
the country
we've seen the president speak publicly
can you talk about any color in terms of
what he's been like behind the scenes
delivering on a campaign pledge yeah
first african-american woman on the
court how he's been with staff with
justice
sure um oh i'm going to try not to ugly
cry about this day which we were all
doing on the south lawn look i i was
with the president before he uh went out
um i i was there on time i didn't run
out as you would have seen i was with
him before when he was reviewing his
mate doing his final review of his
remarks and what he was reflecting on is
um and you saw some of this in his
speech where the number of people
whether it is people who work at the
white house people who are part of his
everyday uh you know stewards or others
who have commented to him how
significant this moment is and how uh
you know in in a place where you are
just trying to trying to make it through
every day and every day is history in
many ways uh history can be
heartbreaking and many days it has been
history can be exhausting in many days
it has been and history can be joyful
and today was a joyful day in history
and that is certainly how the president
was you saw his granddaughter naomi who
he talked about in the speech come out
she was there also
for a brief greet uh with uh with uh
justice jackson um beforehand
and he made a made an effort to also
introduce uh the the new associate
justice to some members of his close
staff who just were inspired by the
significance of today as well so i would
say there was a deep recognition of uh
this moment of history a joy in uh
reaching it and i think we've all been
saying to each other in the hallways no
one can steal our sunshine today because
that's how everybody is feeling
good thank you jen to follow up on that
did the president spend any time with
the jackson family before the formal
event or afterwards i think as we
confirmed she signed uh her commission
or he signed her commission and her
family was with her for that so it was
briefly before he came out to do the
remarks okay um and to follow up on a
question from katie earlier this week
about other precautions
that the president may or may not be
taking do you know if he is taking any
monophonic antibodies to help prevent
catching coverage well ebay sheld is for
immunocompromised that would be the
preemptive step and he's not
immunocompromised so he's not taking
headshot
is he taking any other medication that
might help like what um well i don't
actually know but that's a great
question other than the booster
you know we've heard
other people taking um
other kinds of prophylactics to prevent
it is he taking anything that you know
there are there are not other this is
why i asked there are not other never
shelters obviously one that if you're
compromised something that's been
approved and recommended since he does
not categorize that way he isn't taking
it but other than that the precautions
we're taking are he obviously got the
booster when he was eligible um
last week and uh you know we take
additional steps including testing
socially distance meetings when possible
um as well in order to protect him as
much as possible and then just one more
on something that samantha power shared
she said that russian forces have killed
at least seven journalists in ukraine in
six weeks and that pooped in soldiers
are killing journalists at an
unprecedented rate is there any
intelligence um
any information
that putin is targeting journalists and
do you have any warning that you're
sharing with american journalists uh
covering the war well um
one we we value the role that american
journalists and journalists from around
the world that i felt like a direction
somewhere
um
uh have played in um in uh in bringing
uh
light bringing to light for a lot of
people in this country uh this war
what's happening the devastation the
horrors um it has been a has a direct
impact on people's emotional response in
the united states there's no question
about that
we recognize the war of journalists and
war zones of course and value it and as
you all know we also work very closely
with leaders of news organizations to
ensure that they have up-to-date
information to keep members of their
media organizations safe it is still a
war zone an act of war zone and we're
still conveying that americans should
not be there right including journalists
in terms of specific targeting we knew
from the beginning and we've talked
publicly about this of course that
president putin and the russian military
was going to target was intending to
target or could target civilians and
others including journalists could be
part of that but
i don't have anything any new
intelligence or anything beyond that
thank you good
thanks jen is there a car about in cdc
regulations for copen for vice president
tell me more peter i'm sure this is
going somewhere let's see you know what
do you got for me on a friday the cdc
says for people exposed to cobin up to
date on their covet 19 vaccinations
do not go to places where you are unable
to wear a well-fitting mask so why is
she
here at the white house today
giving the new supreme court justice a
big hug with no mask
you mean when she gave her a hug outside
yes she was outside does the cdc say the
people who are close contact can give
people hugs outside we know peter that
outside it is uh it is uh you are it's
you can benefit significantly being
outside that's why we have we had the
event outside today i will tell you that
the vice president has been wearing a
mask inside when there was a private
greet they were all wearing masks uh
uh
before they went up
yesterday at the senate
she was uh playing an important role in
in confirming or overseeing the
confirmation of the first black woman at
the supreme court the vast majority is
as was on camera peter as was on camera
let me finish my answer here because fox
and other i don't know actually that fox
carried it but others did uh saw that
she was socially distant from people for
the vast vast majority of her time
overseeing uh that confirmation
yesterday so this is not a case of rules
for the but not for vp in fact the vice
president wore a mask inside today when
she was uh it both with the president
with her staff other people she was
outside at the event she was socially
distanced for 99.9 percent of the event
today and she had an emotional moment as
which is understandable okay and one
other topic following up on the
smartphones that are being given to
border crossers with technology so they
can be
tracked or so they can check in is there
any plan to give free smartphones to us
citizens that want them
should we not be tracking uh migrants
who irregularly cross the border i'm
asking if
or do you have an alternative suggestion
for how they should be tracked i
unfortunately have not been asked to
make us immigration policy
today's your moment
well
it'd be great if uh anybody that wanted
a free phone and a free monthly plan
could get one so is that going to be an
offer for everybody or just people that
walk into the country illegally well
peter as when we talked about this the
other day uh what i noted to you is that
we have a range of means of tracking
individuals who irregularly migrate to
the country uh as in to order to ensure
that they are meeting their notice to
appear obligations uh and that they are
appearing in court when they should
appear in court phones is one of them
there are also ankle devices and a range
of tracking devices 80 percent
of individuals have of non-citizens
released at the border from dhs custody
under prosecutorial discretion have
either received a notice to appear are
still within the window to report so yes
there's telephonic reporting there is
smart link which enables participant
monitoring via smartphone there's the
global positioning system these are the
range of means with modern technology
that we monitor last one on this does
the president have any plans to figure
out what these small towns were bracing
for a major influx in migrants next
month need by making his first ever trip
to the border
i have nothing to predict for you in
terms of additional trips the president
will be traveling the country uh but i
don't have any more specifics for you at
this point
earlier you guys told us via pool that
the president was tested net tested
negative that was today
okay so the cadence is clearly changed
right we knew there was one on wednesday
he was negative today's friday tested
negative just for keeping track of isn't
that three times a week two times a week
is there a way to this doctor makes an
assessment on how many times he should
be tested and we do our best to provide
that information to you as he's tested
aside for the time he's done with
katanji brown jackson her family there
was no because there's precedent to this
there was no indoor reception indoor
ceremony that existed some kind of
cameras didn't see before
let me if i can during his remarks today
the president said something was a bit
striking he was condemning some of the
conservative republicans and their
criticisms
of judge jackson which he was testifying
recently he said there was verbal abuse
the anger the constant eruptions those
vile basis file assertions and
accusations
is that a preview of messaging that
we're going to hear from the president
heading into the midterms was that was
that is that a message that the white
house wants to deliver and we'll be
repeating
i don't believe that the conduct of
senators at a hearing is going to be
central to uh the president's remarks
when he's out in
out traveling the country uh but i think
what he was speaking to on a historic
day is that while judge jackson was the
picture now justice jackson was the
picture of dignity in her hearings some
others in the room decided to be the
opposite and he is somebody who has more
experience overseeing supreme court
hearings than anyone living
he has overseen uh them during
republican and democratic presidents and
expects a certain level of conduct
professionalism in decorum and that is
not what we saw for today as opposed to
like a central theme that we'll see in
terms of contrast
i would say that uh that uh i think the
american people can expect that he'll
continue to talk when he's out in the
country for whatever reason about how to
bring down their costs uh how to make
sure that he is fighting for them and
bringing them relief and how he's going
to get the coveted pandemic under
control less about the conduct of
senators at a hearing let me ask a very
good question then on cost if i can
right now the cost of gas in this
country on average is dollars and
fourteen cents does the white house want
a gas tax holiday
it is certainly on the table um and
certainly something we continue to
consider um we have seen a number of
states do that and well um
you know it can have an impact about 18
cents i believe if i remember correctly
uh one of the reasons why we're
considering it uh the the our primary
focus to date as you all know has been
taking steps to increase supply
and get it um get more supply into the
global marketplace but it remains an
option under consideration go ahead the
the un today uh put out a report saying
that global food prices in march reach a
record high
what is the u.s doing if anything to
mitigate a possible additional increases
here
uh here in the united states uh well it
is something that we are certainly
watching very closely while while we
continue to believe that the impact will
largely be in the middle east and uh in
africa i believe uh in a lot of uh you
know other parts of the world less in
the united states um we are continuing
to work our department of agriculture is
continuing to work with farmers and
suppliers about any needs we have here
uh and the president is continuing to
work to bring down costs in a range of
areas for the american people as we
prepare for the impacts of this war it
was pretty widely reported yesterday uh
prior to her covet
diagnosis that speaker pelosi was
planning a trip to taiwan uh beijing
reacted very negatively to that
is the us's divide administration
comfortable if she were to do that such
a high-ranking u.s official
i i don't i think we understood her trip
i don't have any further comments on it
but
thanks jen two questions for you the
first uh today my colleagues in the uk
reported that chancellor of the edge
checker richie sunak
had a u.s green card which he
surrendered this past october
he's been an mp since 2015 and
uscis manuel says that serving in a
foreign government or standing for
election in a foreign government
is not compatible with lawful permanent
resident status
why was this not flagged earlier
i would point you to the state
department or the department of homeland
security i don't have any more comment
from here i mean is it
is it a problem does the presidency is a
problem that
possible for someone to serve at a high
level in a foreign government
and maintain lawful permanent resident
status in the u.s and what if this were
someone who was serving in the russian
duma
it wasn't uh but i would also again
point you to uh the portions of the
government that oversee
green cards and oversee uh you know the
status of documents i'm happy to bump it
for them as well and see if there's more
we can provide question uh there's a
death brother made in texas melissa
lucio she's set to be executed soon
many experts believe her confession was
coerced and is false
she has bipartisan support for clemency
and support from
the eu
and many other foreign allies
would the president consider asking
governor abbott to intervene
well you know the president's position
and view on the death penalty and
there's an ongoing review at the
department of justice at a federal level
this is obviously at a state level i
don't have anything to predict
given his commitment to police reform
would he consider asking the doj to
prohibit police departments that
receive federal funds from using the
read technique for interrogations it's
considered to
create a lot of false confessions well
again i know the department of justice
has taken a number of steps including on
uh chokeholds and other other actions
that needed to be reformed in police
departments across the country i don't
have anything to preview or predict in
terms of additional steps the president
supports their efforts to do more many
of them have talked about their desire
to do more and obviously we are
continuing to consider an executive
order on police reform here given there
has been an inability of congress to
move forward thanks jen uh there's some
pretty desperate images coming out of
shanghai right now which is under
lockdown for kobet
people begging for food and medicine
is the white house monitoring that um is
there anything the us can do to help the
humanitarian situation there and also on
the supply chain front is the
administration aware of any further
supply chain snags coming as a result of
this and how you prepare to address them
sure well first on the the on the first
part of your question the the state
department is closely monitoring the
situation uh they are providing
consistent updates of the situation on
the ground and we'll certainly assess
with usaid and others if there's
additional assistance that could be
provided
on the supply chain
component what we know is that the port
is continuing to operate normally and
where we're seeing the impacts which
which still could could have an impact
over the course of time of course is uh
factories warehouses and trucking where
we are seeing um
shutdowns within the region which we
know could cause delays especially for
air cargo as well uh because this is
just happening we don't have a
prediction at this point on how that
could impact bigger global supply chain
issues it depends on a lot of factors
how long etc
but it is something we are closely
monitoring
and it is something we will continue to
work um to uh to address if if it
extends uh farther there's one more
housekeeping adam do you have a timing
update on when the president might sign
the uh trade preference bill on russia
in the past i don't and i know you and
others have been looking for this and
let me see if i can get an answer before
we all wrap up today go ahead jen could
you speak to the efficacy of sanctions i
know there was a new sanctions package
rolled out this week um
and initially we've heard a lot from
administration officials about this
being returned i know that has changed
um and so can you speak to sort of the
end goal and what is the efficacy of it
well i would say that um
it has we have a couple of objectives um
at this point as it relates to the war
in ukraine one is to
impose uh severe consequences uh send a
marker uh for the world and for history
uh about the uh the horrific nature of
these atrocities um these consequences
and the second part of our objective is
to ensure that these consequences are
having a significant impact on the
economy in russia we're seeing an
inflationary rate of about 15 percent a
projection of a
contraction of 15 in the russian economy
600 private sector companies have left
russia we know it is having the impact
that the world intended this is the most
significant coordinated set of sanctions
ever done in history on this large of an
economy the third objective here is to
make it much more difficult for
president putin to fund his war and if
you look back say earlier this week at
the example of uh the bond payments and
how
russia has basically been put in a
decision
in a place where they either have to use
their limited resources they have that
are also being used to fund the war uh
to prevent a default or default um that
is the position they're in at this point
in time but also because we've cut them
off through export controls and a number
of other means from having access to
materials and technology but also access
to funds it makes it more difficult for
them to fund the war that is part of it
and the last objective uh is to continue
to make it clear that this is a
strategic blunder their their decision
to invade ukraine um and um and one that
will make president putin a pariah in
the world so those are why and what we
are hoping to achieve
is there anything being done
in terms of either monitoring or
actually just i guess monitoring to take
a look at the effects of sanctions on
ordinary russians or anything that the
administration is thinking
um to just deal with that population of
people who are being the russian people
you mean um certain i mean certainly we
are
looking at uh how this is impacting the
russian economy writ large and it is
certainly as as inflation is going up
and as the economy is contracting that
means prices will go up and we do know
there will be a broad impact
that is the fault of president putin and
the fault of president putin invading a
sovereign country uh so it is important
also for the russian people to know and
understand that and we have been working
through a range of means to communicate
about the realities of the war and the
facts of the war through telegram
through youtube through a range of
channels as well
go ahead thanks ted um general milly
earlier this week talked about the
possibility of building a permanent us
bases on nato's eastern flank i wonder
what seriousness the white house has
given that or if you look long-term at
the war in ukraine whether shoring up
the eastern flank with permanent bases
is something that's being considered
there'll continue to be a range of
discussions but i have nothing beyond
what general milley said can i ask one
more question i want to go a little
deeper on the french elections sure does
the white house worry that the election
of le pen could
you know destabilize the nato alliance
or make it difficult being that she's
you know come out with her statements
well i'm just not going to get ahead of
an election in a foreign country um and
obviously we will watch it closely and
i'm sure we'll have more to speak to
once the
results are concluded go ahead thanks um
what can you tell us about the multiple
secret service agents who have been
suspended or removed from the president
vice president
and first ladies detail pending this
investigation of two men impersonating
officers of law enforcement
not much from here i complained to the
secret service and obviously the fbi is
overseeing the investigation is there a
broader concern in the administration
that these principles is there concern
that they're not
being protected effectively can you
speak at all to that or
as i said yesterday we the president
remains confident and the leader of the
secret service um and beyond that i
would point to the secret service and to
the fbi
and then i guess just on the invitations
you issued to republicans who voted to
confirm uh justice jackson i know one of
them has coven but
did you hear from the other two senator
murkowski and romney i know the
president
went a little further to talk about
senator romney's father today
at his speech did the white house hear
from the republicans who were invited
today why didn't they come
i would point you to their offices to
speak to that i mean it doesn't change
the president's gratitude to them for
uh you know bucking the trend uh in in
their party of uh not supporting an
eminently qualified uh nominee uh and
they they did that um and it was
something he wanted to call out today
and express his gratitude thank you yeah
thank you jen i'm wondering what the
white house's reaction
is to yesterday's u.n vote to suspend
russia from the u.n uh human rights
council the fact that there were 58
nations that abstained
from taking a vote and that on top of
the other 24 nations that voted against
it although there was you know more
obviously the majority of countries did
vote to suspend russia but do you think
that this
uh you know that many abstains
abstentions that many people sitting on
the sidelines so this shows that the
entire world really isn't unified around
uh
uh condemning these actions by russia
well a win required two-thirds present
in voting and that is exactly what
happened and and far beyond that
and we know that there were um
abstentions and only 24 countries
including north korea
voted with russia but the outcome which
is what is most important to us is what
we wanted which is russia has been
suspended from the u.n human rights
council suspension just so everybody
knows somebody asked me this question
the other day but is the only method
provided for in the un resolution that
established the human rights council
back in 2005. it's the most serious
action available it's only been applied
once in history this is only the second
time in history that a country has been
kicked out of the u.n human rights
council the last example was libya so
that obviously speaks to the
significance and it also speaks to the
fact that
two-thirds more than two-thirds of
countries who are members um
are um believe that they should not have
a leadership role
on global human rights as they work to
subvert and violate global human rights
this also means that once suspended
russia will not be able to vote against
future actions during subsequent human
rights council sessions and so uh to us
it is significant only the second time
and second time in history and it speaks
to
the global outrage in response to these
atrocities but are there any concerns
that nearly 60 nations uh decided not to
weigh in on this matter again our focus
is on the fact that it was a win for
only the second time in history was a
country kicked out of suspended from the
u.n human rights account another
question uh does president biden still
attempt to intend
to attend the white house correspondents
association uh
dinner here later this month in a couple
weeks we haven't announced his plans to
attend or anything about his schedule so
i don't have any update on that today
all right go ahead and just some
follow-ups to things that came up sure
to follow up on peter's question about
the testing cadence you guys told us
about negative tests on monday wednesday
friday should we expect that the
president would get tested on sunday
two days later i would say i don't have
a prediction of that his doctor makes an
assessment of when he should be tested
and how often and what the cadence
should be it's not always exactly the
same and uh but we will provide
information to you when you test
negative okay or or either way of course
yes uh and to follow up on katie's
question um did the president talk to
any of the senators romney murkowski and
collins after the vote yesterday on
dubai i don't have any update on that
from here okay and when he said he hoped
he didn't get them in trouble today when
you reference them what did he mean by
that i think he meant he recognizes that
the vast majority of
the other members of their party voted a
different way
go ahead thank you um
on india next week secretary state blink
and defense secretary are hosting the
indian counterparts explorer first
minister and country commissioner
for the first india us two plus two
dialogue under this administration
uh what is president masses to the
meeting what is expectations he's
sending
any complete ideas to this meeting as
well uh president biden believes our
partnership with india is one of the
most important relationships we have in
the world
as you know he met with president prime
minister modi and other quad leaders in
march he expects that at this two plus
two secretary blinken and secretary
austin will continue driving forward our
work with india and our shared goals in
the indo-pacific uh region and around
the world uh i we also believe both
sides will continue our close
consultations on the consequences of uh
president putin's brutal war against
ukraine and mitigating the impact by
addressing energy and food prices
obviously it could cover a range of
topics so we expect that to be a central
one and secondly given u.s frustrating
employers it is having in the u.n
security council where one countries are
coming out and controlling all the
issues in ukraine uh
what is basically thoughts on the
reforms the u.n security council said
well i know a question has been asked
about whether russia could be kicked out
of being a permanent member we don't
anticipate that happening uh but
obviously the step taken yesterday to uh
suspend russia from the u.n human rights
uh council is an indication of the
global response and horror at the
atrocities we've seen happen on the
ground in ukraine but beyond that i
don't have any other predictions of
reforms should there be individual veto
or group veto inside the support again i
understand your questions but i don't
have any predictions or calls for that
at this point
okay we'll just do a few more quick
thanks jen since his state of the union
address the president has only made a
handful of domestic trips we've talked
in here before about how he'd like to
get back into the community and have a
chance to interact with american people
is the current covered wave getting in
the way of his travel plans no i expect
he's going to travel a bunch in the next
few weeks okay and you would mention
that you will be going to north carolina
and you didn't have too much more to add
on that but might the president while
he's in greensboro be visiting one of
the areas to historically black colleges
and universities i don't have more
details at this point in time um as they
get finalized i'm sure we'll share them
with all of you
good i think sean i have a two-part
question on student loans
last year president biden directed the
department of education to
create a report on whether he has
presidential authority to unilaterally
do a broad cancellation of debt i don't
believe that's ever been made public and
as you're looking at loan extensions or
loan pause extensions will we can we
anticipate seeing a release of that
report and
secondly as you've talked about how the
president wants to lower costs for
americans
borrowers have expressed stress anxiety
about these short-term extensions what's
your message to them
i think our message to them is that not
a single person has paid a dime on their
student loans since the president took
office and he's continued to evaluate
and assess
with the department of education and
other policy makers in the
administration
what the needs are to lower cost for
people including people who have student
loans and our do feel stressed even as
the economy is continuing to recover but
as we see costs uh too high in some
areas on the first question i don't have
any update on that i would tell you that
if congress were to send him a
bill to cancel his ten thousand dollars
in student loans in student debt he'd be
happy to sign it go ahead last one last
one last one go ahead thank you well um
rachel wallace who was the general
counsel of the science office who the
white house found had been bullied by dr
lander has been told that she will not
be getting her job back as general
counsel uh why
i'm not aware of this personnel update
i'd have to check on it i'm happy to do
that and we will get you back a comment
right uh then a follow-up yesterday you
said when asked about uh vice president
harris's and then asked at the senate
you said that she would follow cdc
protocols at the event today cc
protocols clearly say you should be
wearing a mask doesn't distinguish
between outside and inside so why didn't
you wear a mask and she was socially
distanced for the vast majority of the
event today
standing next to the president about six
weeks away thanks everyone
thank you everyone
you